for this week's classic interview we're
going to go back to when I spoke to
Christopher Petrella back in February of
2014 and this relates to what we often
talk about is a sort of two-tiered
justice system and very often when we
talk about that two-tier justice justice
system we're talking about those people
that are sort of oppressed by that
system we're talking about the
disproportionately poor the
disproportionately non-white
disproportionately people who are in
situations of oppression rather than
privilege and one of the things that is
a necessary analysis to what we saw in
terms of the Moller report and the
subsequent bar report is that the entire
way that Donald Trump was able to sort
of manage the Moller probe including
choosing his own Attorney General who
ultimately was given the opportunity by
Muller to adjudicate whether Donald from
theatre didn't commit obstruction of
justice this is the other side of the
two-tiered justice system appointing
your own Attorney General to adjudicate
your possible crimes is a position of
privilege on the complete other side of
the justice system and when I reviewed
this interview we did with Christopher
Petrella a few years ago that was the
sort of context I was thinking of let's
get into it from February of 2014
Christopher Petrella his research on a
lot of these issues related to the
justice system incarceration privilege
oppression etc Christopher Petrelli is a
PhD student in UC Berkeley's Department
of African American Studies his research
focuses on race class incarceration he's
also a featured blogger at nation of
change Chris you sent me these notes
about what you see as a connection
that's worth discussing between Hyper
incarceration in the United States which
is a topic we talk about a lot on this
program and Occupy Wall Street tell me
what do you have in mind here for our
audience sure well I think the way it
might be helpful to begin would be to
think about what Professor David Harvey
at the City University of New York
states the government does that the
state does during moments of economic
crisis and the term he uses
is accumulation by dispossession which
basically means divesting citizens of
rights and assets in order to at least
as it's justified in order to
restabilized or bring equilibrium back
to the economy and what we see now is
accumulation by dispossession being
being operationalized in two ways one is
through personal indebtedness and think
for example you know structural
readjustment policy on sort of an
individual register and a fine instance
with this would be the fact that
graduates of colleges and universities
right now or coming out with the student
debt law student debt load on average of
about twenty four thousand dollars a
year that's just for a bachelor's degree
never mind you know a master's or
anything beyond that and the second
strategy is to redistribute or
externalize costs from the state body to
who to this to citizens and we so we see
this happening both in public private
and public higher education that's being
privatized and publicly owned and
operated prison facilities that are also
being privatized and if I could just a
quick example we know for example I'm a
PhD student at UC Berkeley we know for
example that the Board of Regents are
proposing around an 81 percent fee
increase and at Berkeley fee is the
euphemistic term we use for tuition an
81 percent tuition increase over the
next four years at a time that the state
of stage facing budget crisis crisis
which means that we as taxpayers in the
state are actually enduring a form of
double taxation we're paying for our
education in the form of taxes and other
social services of course but then were
you know being taxed on top of that with
this fee increase and then in prisons
for example just last month the
Riverside California County of excuse me
Board of Directors at the riverside
county level decided that
we're going to begin charging prisoners
100 $42.42 per day for their stay so
it's a pay to pay program and you see
again the burden the cost being shifted
from the state's back to the most
vulnerable who don't have the money to
begin with anyway yeah we did that story
about the prisons the California prison
charging inmates and you know I think
it's interesting because they both will
eventually have the same undesired
opposite effect of maybe why they're
intended to be put in there I mean with
the prison example we were saying if you
do charge someone for being in prison
and when they leave prison they have
absolutely no money you're you're
creating a situation much more likely
for them to commit a crime that'll land
them back in prison in other words it's
actually having the opposite effect of
making someone no longer a criminal same
thing I think it could apply to the
overwhelming student loan debt burden
right in other words if people have this
incredible student loan debt they are
not necessarily in the criminal sense
but they're going to do things that they
wouldn't otherwise do if they were more
free in other words to kind of pursue
what they want to do so that is that
another similarity it is yeah I mean you
to speak on your first point we know for
example that in California
okay the state of California has the the
highest recidivism rate in the country
and recidivism is a term that basically
refers to the percentage of prisoners
after three years of release that end up
back in a penal institution and it
currently in California the number
stands at about 72 percent which is
lonesomely high and I agree with you you
know one of the very best strategies for
reducing the rate of recidivism would be
to make sure that inmates upon their
release aren't shouldering debt burdens
that are going to put undue strain on
their ability of course to repay or to
get a job for example so I agree and
then of course to your second point in
public education particularly at the the
the level of higher education public
higher education we see a lot of very
very bright students
a lot of students who are publicly
minded and want to work you know in the
realm of sort of public service more
generally finding that they you know
have very few options and then end up on
Wall Street for lack of better for lack
of a better option because they're
shouldering such a large debt load talk
a little bit about hyper incarceration
in the u.s. I mean the statistics are
very clear 5% of the world's population
is in the u.s. 25 percent of the world's
prisoners are in the u.s. now a very
superficial approach might say you know
if it wasn't if there weren't so many
nonviolent drug offenses that landed
people in jail that would solve a huge
portion of it but is that is that
realistic to think that how big of a
problem is the jailing of nonviolent
drug offenders nonviolent drug offenders
it's a it's a problem of excused upon
but capital proportions it's egregious I
mean I'll give you an example so I I'm
27 years old I was born in 1984 1984
since 1984 the the number of bodies
incarcerated in this country has
burgeoned by 400% at a time when the
population has grown ten times as slowly
the number of private prison facilities
since 1984 has grown by four thousand
percent you know there are now you know
ten about ten percent or so of prisons
are for-profit facilities or private
facilities contractor excuse me private
contracts given by the federal
government and we see a situation now
where in in private and public prisons
about 70 percent for example of people
of color are incarcerated for nonviolent
drug related offenses and there are
statistics on this and I'd like to share
one we found that if the state of
California for example emptied its
prisons and released every single inmate
the state and and sent all of these in
these former prisoners to
UC Berkeley UC Merced any of the UCS the
state would actually save about seven
billion dollars per year in other on
paying for their education would be much
cheaper than what it cost to have them
in prison indeed it's very clear I mean
the tuition at UC Berkeley right now
although rising at sort of a rates far
outstripping inflation is still far less
than it is then it costs to incarcerate
someone in a medium-security facility
for example I you know teach at a number
of courses at San Quentin and at San
Quentin the cost of incarcerating a
prisoner is about $47,000 that's in 2010
that's up from about $30,000 in 1990 and
we're talking you know David this is a
medium-security generally medium
security facility death row inmates at
San Quentin cost nearly $200,000 to
incarcerate per year so from a budget
from a budgetary perspective which is a
very slim sort of metric of course this
makes absolutely no sense
it's incredible Kristen there's so much
more to get into and unfortunately we're
just out of time but we'll absolutely
have to have you back
Chris Petrella is a PhD student at UC
Berkeley's Department of African
American Studies he's also a featured
blogger at nation of change really great
to talk to you Chris David thank you so
much